popcorn popcorn popcorn popcorn popcorn
popcorn corn is a food with a very high
frequency that's why we feed it to you
in the feeders this is what I wish they
did in America that they do in England
you can get sweet and salty and mix it
together yourself why don't they do that
here in England you get to choose
between salt and sweet popcorn as I like
I like to mix the two so you're never
quite sure what you're getting kind of
constant element of surprise
it keeps me entertained during the
trailers it's either popcorn and raisin
it I got it I got to have them both
together I can't have one without the
other it's a sweet salty thing I used to
be middle of thing
now I either have to come in really late
to movies I don't want people see me
coming in that's usually all in Tibet I
eat all the things that are like
glutinous and sour
I like when they're shaped like little
creatures I like the ones that are
octopuses I like the ones that are worms
I like the ones that are bears when
they're gelatinous and they are sour
which I like a chewy cinnamon candy I
travel with it my mom raised me on it
I'm the center I have to be on the right
and my family has to be it on the left
of me that's weird I don't know why some
popcorn butter in the middle butter on
top you know you just pump away chemical
stuff butter I know everybody's saying
like the butter from the popcorn places
is like will kill you nobody cares what
are you what do I like to sit where
nobody sees
I like to sit on the floor I would that
would the seat back up and like that I
like to be in the moon
definitely in the seat in DC I do
popcorn butter salt but with Reese's
Pieces in it
do you go to go to the movies have
popcorn right at all I like to sit in
the middle middle towards back I don't
like to be too close to always popcorn
my favorite is just to do butter in the
middle and a classic Red Vine although I
am NOT a Twitter I don't like Twizzlers
I like to sit sort of Center center
Center center is my jam I like to eat
popcorn
it's a classic popcorn and chocolate
because they're delicious I like to eat
popcorn popcorn and some liquid like
water or something
sparkling water what do you guys have in
the UK you guys probably have oh yeah
wine gums
I enjoy wine gums at the movie theater
America has a new thing happening in
movie theatres I can't stand people are
getting like steaks and they're getting
steaks and movie dudes in Korean
theaters we have a peanut butter grilled
squid as a movie it's not dinner it's
dinner and a movie it's not dinner in a
movie which is unusual I don't want to
be sitting next to somebody eat a full
meal while I'm trying to watch I can be
tearing up some chicken tenders or I
could bring in like a chicken salad oh
it's disgusting it's weird it's it's
really good it's culturally all wrong
[Music]